[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition
bonsoir nouvelle édition de votre
journal d'information locale sur tv
60,18 voici les principaux titres de ce
18 décembre
voici tout juste un an et débutaient les
travaux du futur centre de développement
et de recherche de l'entreprise
atos nous irons sur le chantier situé
aux clayes-sous-bois faire le point et
parler et des enjeux avec le responsable
du groupe politique également à suivre
en entretien avec sylvie ce vin montel
tête de liste tous pour villepreux
sylvie ce vin montrent l ancienne
adjointe au maire sortant
et puis j - 7 avant le 25 décembre
encore quelques jours pour trouver des
idées pour le père noël nous allons vous
donner quelques unes de nos idées 100%
yvelinoise le département des
hauts-de-seine officiellement adhérents
du syndicat mixte yvelines numériques
ce rapprochement va permettre
d'accélérer à la mise en commun des
projets avec pour mission l'éducation le
développement de smart city ou encore la
sécurité les différents acteurs du
projet viennent de se réunir pour déjà
présenté un nouveau nom seine et
yvelines numériques mais aussi une
nouvelle identité graphique
ce nouveau logo
ils montrent nos deux territoires ont
numérisé et
et il est intéressant parce qu'il montre
bien que l'apport du territoire alto
séquanais aux yvelines et en superficie
très marginal il est essentiel en termes
de population c'est un doublement de la
population de nos deux départements
c'est plus qu'un doublement de la
richesse puisque des hauts-de-seine sont
un département où l'activité économique
les plus importantes canine
mais c'est un territoire qui finalement
ne va pas grandir démesurément et qui
donc pourra continuer à être plus proche
de ses habitants il a été lancé il y a à
peine plus à d'un an depuis les travaux
ont bien avancé
le chantier du centre de développement
de recherche d'atos situé aux
clayes-sous-bois devrait s'achever à
l'été 2020 elle ce site va accueillir
plus de 400 collaborateurs leurs
missions l'innovation dans le domaine de
l'ordinateur quantique ou encore la
cyber sécurité
le point nicolas landry
ce sera le site de recherche et
développement d'atos aux
clayes-sous-bois le bâtiment diane 8000
m² dédié à l'innovation un
investissement de près de 5 millions
d'euros se fonder des machines de
recherche et développement qui seront
fonctionnels et qui permettront à la
direction recherche et développement de
poids représentait alors qu'on devait
protéger au client les différentes
machines existantes ou développer le
conflit la structure sur deux étages
accueillera entre 400 et 450
collaborateurs
une centaine seront embauchés deux tiers
seront des ingénieurs de recherche et
développement
donc ici une succession de meeting room
à cet endroit là donc c'est ensuite la
bibliothèque et l'espace jeudi
l'objectif c'est de créer aussi à
l'inter de ce centre des espaces de
partage des endroits où les gens vont
pouvoir se regrouper et puis on va
essayer de travailler dans une vision
plutôt systémique décider de nos
machines de nos serveurs de nos super
calculateur de notre sécurité plutôt que
sur une vision très si l'hôte et des
supercalculateurs informatique
l'ordinateur quantique la cyber sécurité
et les innovations de rupture les futurs
thématiques de recherche notamment les
ingénieurs travailleront sur l'avenir de
la quantum learning machine c'est une
machine qui simule le comportement d'un
ordinateur quantique sans avoir
d'ordinateurs quantiques sans avoir de
qubits et ça c'est vraiment très très
utile parce que ça permet de tester le
comportement d'algorithmique anti que
l'on développe et que l'on fait tourner
et ça permet de se préparer
la fin des travaux est prévue à l'été
2001 le déménagement des équipes sera
étalée sur le deuxième semestre de
l'année
c'est une initiative de trois étudiants
en école de commerce la cravate
solidaire a été lancée en 2012 pour
favoriser l'insertion professionnelle
tout en luttant contre les
discriminations liées à l'apparence en
atelier a été organisé à bord d'un
camion aménagé spécialement en dressing
devant la cité des merisiers attrape une
nouvelle étape pour la cravate solidaire
manon varaldo étaient présentes
derrière ces cintres jean michel masson
habitants de trappes et et
manutentionnaire dans la zone
industrielle
il est actuellement en recherche
d'emploi et fait partie des six
personnes qui sont accompagnés par la
cravate solidaire mobile le but de la
cravate solidaire
lutter contre les discriminations liées
à l'apparence en entretien d'embauché
le but principal c'est de revaloriser
aussi l estime de soi des personnes en
insertion professionnelle
jean-michel explique son projet
professionnel aux bénévoles avant son
coaching en images dans ce camion
aménagé en dressing qui serait peut-être
bien ce que vous trouvez une chemise il
va la mission de la coach en image
trouver la tenue idéale pour jean-michel
il faut pas mettre de tichy la coach en
image doit tenir compte des goûts
vestimentaires de jean-michel mais aussi
du poste visé chemise veste chaussures
jean-michel pourra garder cette tenue
professionnelle complète grâce aux dons
perçus par la cravate solidaire mais
dressing de la cravate solidaire est
composé à la fois de dons qu'ils nous
viennent de particuliers de
collaborateurs d'entreprises est
également de marque de textile
métamorphosé jean michel est ensuite
plongé en situation réelle d'un
entretien d'embauché
je recherche d'emploi il efface un
binôme de responsables en ressources
humaines qui lui donne les clés pour se
mettre en valeur et renvoyer une bonne
image lors de ces futurs entretiens
pour l'instant je reste toujours sur
l'objet du genre pour voir si ça va être
confirmées ou pas si ça va pas
pendant la chasse aux coûts à la fin de
l'atelier jean michel repart avec une
photo pour son cv ou les réseaux sociaux
professionnels et surtout un regain de
confiance en lui nous allons maintenant
prendre la direction de guyancourt pour
une parenthèse sportive le club local de
tir à l'arc qui vient d'organiser son
concours annuel au gymnase maurice
baquet comme chaque année depuis plus de
25 ans maintenant plusieurs centaine
d'archers ont tiré durant tout le week
end avec au programme des finales par
poule
à partir du moment où on a mis en place
cette organisation de concours et ce
type d'événement on a la chance que ça
attire des archers qui sont de très bon
niveau et du coup ça nous permet d'avoir
sur une même compétition aussi bien des
archers qui sont dans leurs premières
années le tir à l'arc et puis qui sont
en progrès ou des gens qui viennent là
avec un objectif à guyancourt c'est
toujours une compétition qui est
sympathique puisque du coup il ya des
matches l'après midi donc c'est rare
dans la région et c'est une compétition
qui est bien placé en termes de
calendrier juste avant noël juste avant
les grosses complète de janvier invité
de ce journal à présent pierre rivère
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue en plateau
vous êtes auteur écrivain installé dans
les yvelines noisy le roi est votre
troisième ouvrage s'intitule world games
quelqu'un c'est alors avant de parler du
même du contenu j'ai évoqué le troisième
ouvrage mail ouvrage qui apparaît là à
l'écran n'est que le premier à être
publié
pourquoi vous avez fait des essais avant
parce que comme d'autres disciplines
artistiques je considère que l'écriture
est quelque chose qui se travaille
donc j'ai émis une dizaine d'années à
apprendre à écrire alors on apprend
généralement écrire à l'école en
revanche pour arriver à une quelque
chose qu'on estime digne d'être mis
entre les mains de deux lecteurs je
pense qu'il faut effectivement un peu de
temps donc j'ai en effet fait une
démarche d'apprentissage pour être
auteur de romans à suspense
est-ce que vous avez travaillé dans le
sport automobile dans les jeux vidéo
aussi et puis parallèlement vous vouliez
vous avez toujours voulu être auteur
maintenant cet ouvrage est publié
il est plutôt plutôt conséquent
disponible à la fois en version brochet
et puis en version électronique aussi
donc vous travaillez encore aujourd'hui
une insulte and we suis consultant dans
le tourisme ce qui me permet de vivre ma
démarche d'auteur et en naissante
il faudra sans doute encore un petit peu
d'années avant que je puisse ne me
consacrer à l'écriture uniquement alors
parlons du livre world games polar
mêlant fiction fait d'actualité
nouvelles technologies le fait
d'actualité c'est la sphère xavier
dupont de ligonnès ce père de famille
soupçonné d'avoir assassiné et toute sa
famille en 2011
introuvable depuis un fait divers qui
vous a passionné le début qui m'a
intrigué dès le début et qui m'a au fil
des années passionné par ce que on a
l'impression que c'est une affaire qui
s'est arrêtée le 15 avril 2011 quand on
a eu l'année dernière trace de xavier
dupont de ligonnès est depuis il s'est
passé plein de choses sans doute est en
tout cas dans dans la tête d'un
romancier il se passe plein de choses et
donc c c'est de cette affaire dont je me
suis servi comme un décor pour pour mon
roman
ce n'est pas du tout une enquête ou un
essai sur sur la sphère serre mais un
départ c'est un point de départ c'est un
décor et c'est on va dire la une une
quête de deux des héros de mon livre
pour se demander quelle pourrait être la
méthode pour retrouver xavier dupont de
ligonnès s'il était vivant et comment
dépasser on va dire les méthodes
policières classiques donc ça reste un
décor mais mes héros de romans sont tout
à fait fictionnel unique saviez dupont
de ligonnès revenu dans l'actualité la
sphère revenu dans l'actualité et
l'actualité yvelinoise même puisque son
arrestation a été donc dans un premier
temps annoncé du côté de lui mais ces
derniers mois finalement c'était une
erreur ça a nourri votre roman ce qui
s'est passé pendant cette période vous
êtes vraiment partie du point de départ
et ensuite vous avez recommencé broder
autour de tout ça il ya un travail de
recherche comment vous allez travailler
alors je me suis effectivement beaucoup
documenté sur la faire et j'ai été
surpris de constater que depuis 2011 en
fait depuis que l'on recherche des
traces de xavier dupont de ligonnès on a
eu près 2000 signalements
tous fu chi chi donc s'avèrent être des
fausses pistes et tous ces signalements
émane de de la france ou de pays
limitrophes
à quelques exceptions près et donc moi
je me suis plutôt de demander si xavier
dupont de ligonnès avait refait sa vie à
l'autre bout du monde
comment on pourrait le retrouver parce
que votre héros s'appelle axel clark il
est pilote de ligne il se retrouve nez à
nez à l'étranger justement très loin
d'ici
avec xavier dupont de ligonnès et
ensuite c'est une chasse à l'homme voilà
où ou avec quelqu'un qu'il pensait le
gravier dupont de ligonnès et comme dans
la vie de ce héros il ya également un
drame puisqu'il a perdu la femme qu'il
aimait je dirais cette espèce de
catalyse entre deux portes l'une très
médiatique et l'autre très personnelle
le font rentrer dans un processus de
direct comment je pourrais mettre une
organisation qui permette de retrouver
xavier dupont de ligonnès et ils
inventent world games qui est la trame
de mon roman
alors sans dévoiler bien évidemment la
faim et le dénuement comment vous avez
organisé cet ouvrage pour le laisser
suffisamment on va dire ouverts parce
que le but ce n'est pas de résoudre
cette affaire xavier dupont de ligonnès
n'ont très prétentieux de vouloir le
faire
donc comme je vous le disais je suis
partie de ce qui s'est passé en 2011 et
gels et j'ai d'abord fait travailler mes
héros si j'ose dire sur la réflexion de
dire est ce que xavier dupont de
ligonnès s'est suicidé ou bien est-ce
qui s'est enfui et puis très vite mais
c'est pas mon avis c'est l'avis de mes
héros ils pensent que xavier dupont
ligonnès s'est enfui parce que il ya
chez eux une sorte d'antagonisme absolue
entre la possibilité qu'il se soit
suicidé qui est une sorte d'appel ou de
détresse d'appel au monde quelles que
soient les raisons du suicide
et puis le fait d'être disparu dit
autrement un suicide et disparus ça
n'existe pas ou c'est rarissime en tout
cas dans les annales des affaires
criminelles
donc le mérou pense qu'il ne s'est pas
suicidé ils se disent maintenant s'il
habite à l'autre bout du monde comment
on fait pour le retrouver pour plus dans
la mesure où son signalement n'ai connu
que des européens ou des français et
donc non je disais et aidons qui il
trouve en fait le talon d'achille de
xavier dupont de ligonnès si tant est
qu'il soit vivant qui est de dire mais
en fait l'histoire qui justifie dans son
nouvel entourage que il est apparu en
2011 que ce soit en tanzanie en
thaïlande au brésil où
peu importe où dans le monde et bien ce
cette histoire qui leur sert est
nécessairement fausse puisque avant 2011
on sait parfaitement où il était en
france mélanger fiction avec la réalité
exercice toujours un peu compliqué ça
vous a plu vous avez déjà d'autres idées
de romans sur le même fonctionnement
alaoui suis fasciné par par ce lien
entre la réalité et la fiction par les
moments où comme on dit souvent la
réalité dépasse la fiction parce que
même dans l'imaginaire d'un auteur ou il
ya des faits réels qui fasciné et qui
sont des instruments des sujets c'est là
un autre qui me fascine qui est la
disparition du vol mh3 170 quelques
années après laffaire dupont de ligonnès
donc j'ai pas encore trouvé l'angle pour
en faire un roman et encore une fois je
ne suis pas enquêteur aux journalistes
mais mais ça me fascine également oui
merci beaucoup pierre prévert d'être
venu sur ce plateau je rappelle cet
ouvrage world games quelqu'un ses
éditions libre à nova disponibles
version électronique version papier
également merci à vous c'est l'idée de
cadeau pour noël
et puis justement des idées de cadeaux
pour noël nous allons vous en donner à
présent encore quelques-unes des cadeaux
a glissé au pied du sapin des idées 100%
yvelinoise sélection de rire 11 cette
année pour remplir sa hotte le père noël
va devoir parcourir plusieurs kilomètres
premier arrêt sans fard ni vim c'est ici
qu est implanté son taux ce faire cette
société existe depuis plus de 30 ans
elle imagine dans ses locaux des jeux
sensoriels inspiré de la méthode
montessori ou encore des kits de loisirs
créatifs c'est pas uniquement le petit
jeu sur lequel on joue pendant dix
minutes c'est réellement des choses on
va avoir un apprentissage on va avoir et
on est vraiment sur le premier le
principe de faire les choses soi-même de
réaliser des choses on est dans un monde
où on va de plus en plus vite c'est
aussi des jeux qui vont prendre leur
temps avec ses boîtes en carton 100%
recyclable sentosphère mise aussi sur
l'écologie une valeur partagée par une
autre société
direction versailles où s'est installée
depuis peu le siège social de nature et
découvertes
depuis sa création en 1990 l'enseigne
s'est spécialisé dans les produits de
bien-être des produits également liés à
la biodiversité
parmi les cadeaux plébiscités cette
année ce nichoirs pour oiseaux ou encore
ces jouets pour les tout petits
et nous avons aussi cette année leur
lancement de notre gamme pour les 0 à 3
ans qui s'appelle gallopin des bois king
am devait jouer très vertueuse
parce que nous n'utilisons que du coton
bio pour les enfants nous utilisons du
bois fsc de forêts gérées durablement et
enfin dieu la peinture sans solvant pour
les plus grands nature et découvertes
mise notamment sur une valeur sûre la
lecture un des coups de coeur en livrent
en ce moment c'est le livre vivre avec
la terre de charles hervé gouyer de la
ferme du bec hellouin qui nous apprend
les grands principes de la permaculture
et qui est un très très beau cadeau à
offrir
[Musique]
depuis 2015 la nostalgie à son royaume à
mouiller c'est ici qu est installée la
société naftal gift points comme ce site
internet propose des articles sur le
thème de la nostalgie des jouets des
bonbons qui nous font voyager dans le
temps
3000 produits sont référencés on voit
souvent dans les tendances les gens qui
créent leur coffret avec plein de petits
bonbons et justement ils vont mettre un
jeu d'eau agnès et vous faire leur petit
coffret pour que les imagine les
personnes retombe en enfance
des coffrets nostalgique proposé entre
30 et 40 euros
dans un instant nous ouvrirons une page
politique municipale 2020 en attendant
cinéma comme chaque mercredi nous sommes
allés à votre rencontre à la sortie des
salles qu'avez vous pensé du si attendu
derniers épisodes de star wars
[Musique]
je suis star wars depuis 1977 quand j'ai
vu le premier épisode
donc j'étais au collège et aujourd'hui
je vois la fin de cette saga c'est
peut-être il fallait que l'histoire se
termine et elle se termine de façon
magnifique quel personnage c'est un peu
démarqué dans ce cas
quelle est leur aide et rei il y avait
beaucoup d'attentes sur ce qu'allait
faire ré en terme de ce qu'elle va
basculer du côté obscur ou pas moi j'ai
bien aimé la manière dont l'intrigué tu
es mené leur niveau mise en scène c'est
au top
évolution des personnages c'est au top
music au top aussi
donc si on n'a pas aimé le mythe on peut
quand même donner sa chance aux neuf
vaut mieux avoir aimé le set et avoir vu
le set au 6 mai faune y aller voir le
regretterez pas passons la page
politique si vie sauve à montels bonsoir
vous êtes élu depuis 2008 à villepreux
ancienne adjointe au maire sortant
stéphane mirambeau et depuis quelques
semaines en campagne dans le cadre de
ces élections municipales 2020 tête de
liste tous pour villepreux ce sera une
liste sans étiquette sans investiture
sans soutien c'est le choix que vous
avez fait tout à fait c'est un choix que
nous avons fait moi ainsi que mes
colistiers sans étiquette c'est à dire
que nous n'avons aucun soutien d'aucun
parti politique et c'est ça leur est le
réel sujet du sans étiquette
même si elle est collaboratrice de
gérard larcher président de l ère du
sénat toute transparence n'a pas de
soutien viendra pas se tenir aux modes
campagne pas fait parce que on estime
que ce soit moi je me mens prime excusez
moi et mes colistiers que le soutien
dont nous avons besoin son soutien des
villes provient et pas de parti
politique et j'entends la sueur des
élections municipales ça prend vraiment
du sens
ces propos lors vraiment du sens donc
non politisée une liste municipale comme
la nôtre sur une ville comme villepreux
je pense que cette annonce ans je pense
que les villes projets n'ont pas besoin
de ça et n'ont pas besoin de soutien
partis politiques civiles ont besoin de
l' inverse ils ont besoin du soutien de
leur maire et nous on a besoin de leur
soutien c'est ça l'essentiel
alors qui composent cette liste je les
préciser vous êtes ancienne adjointe au
maire aujourd'hui donc vous construisez
cette liste sans étiquette il ya des
anciens de nos élus qui vous ont rejoint
des nouveaux des nouveaux aussi
le plus jeune a 18 ans a fait de bien
renseigner oui complètement
donc c'est une liste très mixte très
très mélangé il ya toutes les origines
il ya tous les âges ca de 18 ans a
retraités et jeunes retraités en passant
par tous les âges différents milieux
sociaux face est en fait une liste qui
représente la ville c'est une liste où
on va retrouver des personnes dans tous
les quartiers donc tous les quartiers
sont représentées toutes les tous les
styles de vie sont représentés on va
retrouver vite que dans cette liste et
c'est ça c'est ça l'objectif
l'unique objectif c'était ça mais je
pense ou même la question dans quel état
d'esprit êtes vous aujourd'hui puisque
on leur dit vous êtes une ancienne
adjointe au maire vous avez vu vos
délégations retirer juste avant l'été
dans un contexte assez difficile je
rappelle qu'il ya toujours une plante en
instruction actuellement pour
harcèlement sexuel envers à stéphane
mirambeau le maire sortant qui lui aussi
va se représenter
aujourd'hui vous vous êtes dans quel
état d'esprit revancharde quelques pas
ou pas du tout alors d'abord c'est pas
du tout mon tempérament d'être
revancharde je n'ai jamais été j'ai pas
qu'halfen rancunier par contre quand on
fait du mal je suis pas amnésiques
ça c'est le premier point donc non
revanche ap absolument pas le l'histoire
des plaintes je veux même pas en
entendre parler sur le sujet n'était pas
là c'était par rapport au retrait des
délégations sans eau qui sont 60
prévenir et sans rien me dire
donc c'était une sacrée surprise cet été
bien aidé par un certain nombre d'élus
qui étaient autour de lui qu'il
soutenait à l'époque on va pas revenir
là dessus je me suis piquée au conseil
municipal du 27 24 septembre
donc là tu tout a été dit donc je
préfère fermer le fermer le livre
c'était beaucoup plus simple
et quand vous dites tel état d'esprit
donc je suis dans un très bon état
d'esprit
tu nous as un état d'esprit où je vais
de l'avant dans le livre il est fermé
chants touré de gens bienveillants
ça fait beaucoup de bien et je veille à
ce que cette bienveillance le reste est
donc au contraire un très bon état
d'esprit pour aller avec une feuille de
route jusqu'au mois de mars avec
confiance de plus en plus dans les
villes prodia qui feront le bon choix
on va parler de vos propositions dès les
premières propositions le programme bien
évidemment comme pour l'ensemble des
candidats qui passent en plateau avec
seulement est encore en cours
d'élaboration le scrutin a lieu le 15
mars mais comme vous faites partie
malgré tout la majorité sortante
est-ce que vous assurer une partie de ce
bilan alors c'est une très bonne
question je remercie jo wilfried
évidemment quand on a été élu pendant
quasiment 12 ans dans la majorité ça
serait une grave erreur de dire non je
fais un reset et je n'en n'ont bien
évidemment que le bilan m'appartient
aussi je suis né du sortant je suis la
seule tête de liste la salle du ski et
sortantes puisque aux dernières
informations le maire ne se présentera
pas en tant que tête de liste
ça c'était la nouveauté d'hier donc donc
du coup je suis là évoluent vite puisque
météo suivre je vous conseille d'aller
sur les réseaux sociaux tous les jours
ils tre mais faire ce que ça change
après tout le temps donc en tout cas je
suis là c'est peut-être de liste
sortante c'est vrai aussi que ce bilan
donc je me gagne évidemment que je le
porte
il est évident quand on est élu dans la
majorité pendant onze ans et demi
ce serait ça serait stupide de dire je
ne ne porte pas par contre je reprends
aussi ma liberté je suis quelqu'un
d'extrêmement et loyal gelé souvent dit
je les dis leur demande internationaux
dernier conseil au mois de septembre
c'est vrai que moi dans la loyauté quand
j'étais pas d'accord je le talent est
pas sur la place publique
il y avait quelques petits points de
désaccord donc je reprends ma liberté et
c'est là où le promo programme risque de
surprendre un petit peu j'en donnerai un
peu plus de détails au mois de janvier
mais par une tête le point de ce
programme tout de même la sécurité
peut-être vous l'avez d'ores et déjà
annoncé vidéoprotection bien évidemment
la sécurité que j'ai porté pendant cinq
ans et demi bien évidemment c'était déjà
arrêté parle exactement ça ma délégation
ça s'est arrêté comme un couperet bien
évidemment je n'ai pas terminé ce que je
voulais faire et que ce sera une de mes
priorités de nous pourrir une priorité
pour le mandat suivant
après il y en a bien d'autres vous savez
comme une cerise
ce qui est important pour les électeurs
c'est que chaque électeur
chaque électeur se retrouve dans le
programme on va porter tous les sujets
sont importants la sécurité bien
évidemment l'environnement
tout le monde parle de l'environnement
bien évidemment nous on a on a un bilan
très positif sur l'environnement vide
preuve extrêmement positif zéro phyto de
la cantine j'ai pas tout citer
mais donc bien évidemment c'est juste
ces sujets là vont rester très important
mais ce que nous souhaitons dans notre
liste c'est que chaque ville rosien qui
va lire notre programme se dira j'ai pas
été oublié et je suis dedans c'est ça
notre objectif donc des fois ça pète sur
des petites choses
donc rien ne sera oublié personne ne
sera oublié c'est ça l'essentiel
aujourd'hui le programme se construit
encore vous avez plusieurs réunions et
thématiques pour recevoir recueillir les
propositions les remarques
mais tout à fait on a fait on avait une
semaine très chargée la semaine dernière
ce qu'on a fait cinq réunions 5 plutôt
ateliers publics de quartier on s'est
déplacé dans chaque quartier pour
justement recueillir les avis les
retours de la population mais dans les
quartiers donc sa consonance a concerné
des idées à la fois général et de leur
quartier ça c'était important pour nous
qu'on se déplace vers chez des électeurs
vers chez des administrés et ce qui
était très intéressant on a été très
agréablement surpris de voir que des
retours que les personnes ne faisait et
répondait complètement à notre programme
répondait à leurs attentes et que du
coup on est plutôt c'est pas confiant
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de travail à
faire d'information et de communication
mais les retours qu'on en a eu
on s'est dit ils les attendent dévié de
freudien on est sur la bonne voie ça
correspond pas mal aux attentes qu'ils
ont dans notre programme ils vont ils
vont s'y retrouver quelle est la tante
la plus forte qui s'est exprimée selon
vous jusqu'à présent alors via la
sécurité qui ressort qu'un évidemment
c'est des sujets très généraux au niveau
national finalement la sécurité et puis
évidemment le cadre de vie et l'art
peuvent être beaucoup de choses dedans
c'est la famille c'est cadre de vie ça
dans ces enveloppes beaucoup de choses
et en fait on retrouve beaucoup beaucoup
ce côté je vais être bien chez moi je
reste bien dans ma ville c'est ce qu'on
retrouve de plus en plus et notamment à
villepreux qui comme une ville à la
campagne ou bien évidemment c'était ça
fait partie de notre adn est en tout cas
en tant qu'élu gelé depuis longtemps ça
se répand depuis longtemps via la
campagne qui a rejoint néanmoins une
agglomération celle de saint quentin en
yvelines au cours du mandat qui vient de
s'écouler
quel regard vous portez sur cette
intégration au sein de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et quelles
attentes vous pouvez avoir parce que la
campagne se joue partie aussi là puisque
on le rappelle une nouvelle fois les
électeurs vont désigner leurs élus leurs
mères pour le conseil municipal mais
aussi les élus qui vont siéger au sein
d'une agglomération donc il y aura
ensuite à des projets à porter au sein
des agglomérations quel regard vous
faites sur l'intégration jusqu'à présent
et depuis qu'elle attende vous pouvez
avoir pour la suite alors beaucoup de
choses ont avancé ce qu'on est rentrée à
saint quentin en yvelines en janvier
2016 donc ça fait déjà quelques années
c'est vrai que ça pète et simple au
départ il faut pas se mentir on a on est
à paris pendant très longtemps comme les
rentrants que les entrants les nouveaux
entrants
c'est beaucoup moins le cas aujourd'hui
il ya encore beaucoup de travail à faire
j'ai défendues depuis le mois de
septembre ne fait que j'ai une
délégation au sein de saint quentin en
yvelines parce que 1000 protée quasiment
pu représenter et ça c'était juste pas
possible pour moi
ce que je souhaite c'est ta mère une
mère extrêmement présente au niveau de
saint quentin en yvelines beaucoup de
choses sont décidés et qui ont aligné
avec la vie au quotidien des habitants
de plus en plus de délégation de pouvoir
sur la mezzanine quelque chose de lassus
suis assez sceptique aussi sceptique et
des fois un peu à peu inquiète je pense
que saint quentin en yvelines et de
façon globale les intercommunalités ne
doivent pas prendre trop de compétences
à mon avis il y en a certaines qui
pourraient être enlevés il ya des
compétences facultatives
il ya des bons il faut faire attention
et je pense qu'on aura le temps de
reparler tout ça se sait que vous allez
organiser un débat je pense que ça va
être intéressant
moi je tendance à dire qu'il faut
peut-être un peu freiné les compétences
à tout va à la carco je pense que c'est
pas une très bonne idée et qu'il faut
que les maires gardent leurs compétences
principales et même d'autres
chez eux et soient maîtres de leurs de
leur commune
donc là dessus un peu plus critique
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau est
sylvie ce vin montel candidate donc tous
pour villepreux opposé dans ce scrutin
sur sept communes notamment à une liste
porté par le modem et les rues m
l'ancien maire éventuellement alors vous
nous disiez peut-être pas tête à tête de
liste mais voilà et puis également
marie-valérie bain dont nous avons déjà
parlé sur cette antenne l'ensemble des
candidats et qui seront à déclarer
auprès de la préfecture seront bien
évidemment convient un débat vous l'avez
évoqué l ce sera au courant du mois de
février merci à vous merci un dernier
mot de politique avec coignières le
maire sortant didier fischer annoncé sa
candidature avec la liste un élan
durable pourquoi n'y est réélu fin 2018
après la démission de jean-pierre
sevestre il entend avoir cette fois ci
la possibilité d'un mandat complet pour
poursuivre les mesures mises en place
deux axes prioritaires développement
durable culture
parmi les enjeux également mais sur le
long terme cette fois-ci restructuration
des zones d'activités ou encore quartier
de la gare prochain point sur
l'actualité locale ce sera demain jeudi
dans un instant le 7-8 débat présenté
préparé par et grégory canal et ce mois
ci il sera question avec ses invités de
la sécurité des sites seveso dans le
département belle soirée
[Musique]